eventually once we've done that and
we've for example create an event the
early event called go for europe and we
started getting invested from all over
the world including china
and u.s so we decided to rebrand our
annual event and to and we started
calling it go for israel which is more
reflective of what we really want to
achieve to uh
convince uh
international investors to go for israel
we've done for example five events in
china from one thousand to three
thousand people one of the events we had
the 300 entrepreneurs from israel
and uh
we always enjoy when we have the
opportunity to promote israeli companies
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we're going to be talking
about the history of the israeli
high-tech ecosystem with edward kukirman
founder and managing partner of catalyst
investments and serves as the chairman
of cookierman and company investment
house
since his establishment in 1993 kukirman
and company investment house has been
engaged in more than 8 billion
cross-border transactions across
industries catalyst investments was
established in 1999 by eduard
kuchiermann jayer shamir and bazarel
with over 300 million dollars under
management the fund supports the
long-term growth of medium-sized israeli
companies with innovation in global
markets
edward cookierman welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm fine thank you for hosting me
thank you
thank you very very much for being here
i'm so honored to have you here you know
really one of the pioneers of the
israeli tech ecosystem there's no other
way to say this uh with with catalyst
investments and cookierman
investment a a co-investment house and
you've been investing in israel i think
you know just about 1999 at least from
catalyst investments and you've seen
what's happening with the startup nation
and
you know with our conversation right
before this you're talking about it not
just from you know a financial point of
view but really from a zionist point of
view and and your love for this place
and your love for what's happening here
and and you know if you go going through
the website immediately you're talking
about mature israeli companies which is
not you know the traditional way that
vc's talk talking about growing maturing
companies in this ecosystem so i'm
really excited to dive deep with you in
these 20 minutes welcome
thank you and
i'm glad to join uh doesn't make me
younger when you tell about
my history but it's true that i started
my flash my first venture fund in 1993
so it was 28 years ago and
at that time we were only three venture
funds in israel three today there are
israeli venture funds plus 100
international funds so the
the industry has evolved in an amazing
way in the last 28 years
take me back 28 years 1993
why start a vc fund nobody's doing it
why are you doing it
you know at the time i just came back
from insead i did my mba in
fontainebleau
i studied in the technion and i studied
during my studies my mbs study i i
thought about what could be interesting
to create after my mba
and the
venture industry is something that
attracted me i studied before in the
technion and i used to
work during my studies to help technion
licensing their technology to european
companies and what we've seen is that
many of the
entrepreneurs or people that develop
technology a difficulty getting funding
that's why i saw that
while i was studying there i
work on a business plan how to create a
venture fund
which is something i implemented just
after my studies
tell me the story of the founding of it
and you know how does it actually all
take place i mean the real kickoff of
our investment banking activity was when
we took our own venture fund public in
1997 in europe it was at the first time
the first ipo of an israeli company in
continental europe
i did that the time with my father and
uncle they were both heroes of french
banks and eventually we had
5 000
european investors
when the first fund i managed went
public in 97.
it was doing mostly early stage
investments
and the ecosystem evolved we moved from
three players back in 93 to 100 venture
funds in 1999
and we felt that the market becoming
more competitive on the early stage we
started shifting our investment strategy
to investments in more mature companies
and uh in 1999 two of my partners joined
me at the time
towards the year chamier and boras
and we have been working together for 21
years
investing in disruptive technology
companies
some of the companies became
quite famous for example we were the
only venture fund that invested in
mobileye
and
some of them went recently public on the
york stock exchange so
uh
the last two transactions were the ipo
of
tabula and the ipo of arbay
so we have seen quite a lot of unicorns
being built under
the
with the funding of cannabis and we're
quite proud of that
incredible incredible 1993-1997
or 1999 where you know you're growing
the israeli ecosystem is is maturing
fast and you're making the transition
from focusing on early stage investments
to growth investments and and soon we'll
shift the conversation to talking about
you know what it takes to build a mature
company in an ecosystem like israel but
what happens in israel at that point
from your eyes what is happening to our
landscape
that we're seeing this boom of
investments coming in
well one of the challenges that
had impacted the industry is the crisis
of 2000 and the crisis of 2008.
uh at the time
there were a lot of mid-market players
that were taking israeli companies
public
at a quite early stage
remember probably the
uh lehman brothers all the students hmq
and many montgomery securities and
others that
we're going we're taking israeli
companies public at valuation around 100
million dollars
and after those two crisis almost all
the mid market players disappeared
and the lead bankers whether it's city
goldman sachs jp morgan and others they
are all looking
for
unique ones companies that are valued
above 1 billion in order to take them
public on the nasdaq
therefore there was a need for
additional funding so that those
companies israeli company could grow to
reach a critical size of sales of above
100 million dollars in order to be ready
for an ip on the nasdaq and it creates a
lot of pressure on many
early stage companies that couldn't get
funding so that's one of the reason why
we shifted our investment strategy to
mature companies if you look at the
statistics today out
if you uh see for transaction where the
exit is above 100 million
it takes on average 16 years from the
day that the company was established to
the day the exit is realized
and the early stage venture fund very
often even if they are a great portfolio
company are getting stuck in companies
where they don't have liquidity during
the life cycle of the fund this is one
of the reasons why we allocate more
resources in mature companies and also
doing direct secondary transactions
wow okay and so you're building you're
talking about growth and you're talking
about mature companies
it's the talk talk about mature
companies that you've started a long
time ago you know from from a young
entrepreneur's lens really is only
taking israel by a storm in the last few
years
what's the vision behind mature
companies so what and and why go
so early you know before other players
talking about growing mature companies
within israel
i mean the uh
the big problem is the time to exit
which i explained and we had also the
need of getting private funding
uh before doing an mma or going public
and as there was a growing demand
uh for many many years the israeli
companies were focused on developing
technologies and once they had
uh
working technology they would sell it
through a strategic alliance or an m a
to a to a
international group that would market
the final product to the end consumer i
think the key uh
change happened when if you look at the
first unicorn of israel
it was ways
that uh
reached a value of above one billion
dollar and that was the first company
that sold their product or provided
their pro product to the consumer to the
end consumer
the internet changed a lot of things in
the industry and uh
many of the unicorn of today there are
currently 66 unicorns in israel if you
look at those unicorns many of them sell
their service or their product to the
end consumer that was something that was
not possible during the 90s and the
early 2000 years
uh you had to go through uh
cisco uh microsoft in order to provide
the solution to the end consumer
today it's a very different
ballgame we have
in israel people that have online
marketing expertise that knows how to
get access to the consumer and and
majority now the unicorn are going
directly to the consumer so the market
is not limited for uh
an entrepreneur they can get access to
the final client
and israeli players become global
players that's a trend that is kind of
growing and we are benefiting from these
growths
remarkable
edward tell me about your story
you know both 28 years of venture
capital but also why why focusing on
israel for 28 years you know you're
you're coming from france right what is
your story
i mean i
i was uh
educated uh in france but my mom is is
ready and my father is french
uh
finally it's part of the value that
we've been
exposed to since we're a kid i was
spending all my summer in israel from
the day
from the from a young age and uh
for me the key uh the key element that
triggered my venue in israel was the
fact that during
the first lebanese war i felt very bad
to stay in france
and i wanted to serve my country so i
still a
reserve officer in the army and i'm very
proud that also my
three kids served in an interesting
position in the army and still serving
for some of them
and
that was part of the values and also i
think the
value of the people surrounding me also
in my firm
i have
you know
that was minister in the previous
government and was arrested that have
been a very
big supporter of israel but also some of
my investors that backed me from the
beginning like the
auto group
and and other european investors that uh
supported our activities for
28 years with the idea of helping
israeli companies to become market
leaders
and
and we enjoyed doing that until today
was that was that a part of the core
vision 28 years ago when you or you know
throughout the 28 years is this
something that is that is you know top
of mind for you you know your role
within within the israeli ecosystem
besides the financial and upside part of
the venture capital world
i have to tell you that it's uh
interesting to see the presentation i
had when i started my activity 93
is very similar to
the
organic arm the organizational structure
of
today of the group
we have
we had this vision of trying to help
israeli companies to first to to develop
their activities in europe that was the
initial vision that's because of our
uh family network and and our link to
europe uh but eventually once we've done
that and we've for example create an
event the early event called go for
europe and we started getting invested
from all over the world including china
and
in the u.s so we decided to rebrand
our annual event and to and we started
calling it go for israel which is more
reflective of
what we really want to achieve to uh
convince uh
international investor to go for israel
we've done for example five events in
china from one thousand to three
thousand people one of the events we had
the 300 entrepreneurs from israel
and uh
we always enjoyed when we had the
opportunity to promote israeli companies
worldwide i actually wrote a book which
is called israel valley that was
translated in
quite a few languages today to explain
about the israeli ecosystem and why
israel has been
a success story in the high-tech sector
and i
and i'm very happy that people read it
in brazil in china in russia in italy
so it's really uh in france obviously so
i
i'm
i've been trying to promote israeli high
take for many years and it's a better
way to promote israel than to speak
about
geopolitical problem and other military
problems we are faced uh uh
we're facing obviously
i did that enough for during my military
duty a spokesperson
of
israel with
some european media so now
i have seen how challenging it is to
speak with
people as part of the idf uh
but it's much and it's a much easier job
to do it when you try to
present the unicorn of israel to
the financial community
i i love it i love it so i have a
question for you
young entrepreneur sitting in front of
you right now and you know we're in a
space where you know the world is
globalized and through technology you
know anything can be done and you know
thankfully within our experience in
israel so a lot of us have experience
with deep technology that has the
capacity to really make meaningful
changes and i want to know what does it
take what do i need to keep in mind in
order to build a truly mature company
and and i want to keep that intention
from the get-go so with your 28 years of
experience and i can only imagine how
many thousands of companies you've seen
their their journey what should i as a
young entrepreneur keep in mind as i'm
starting on my journey and until i reach
that mature phase what should i be
constantly telling myself and keeping in
mind you know i think that many of the
israeli entrepreneurs have a very
technology-oriented
a strong technology orientation
many of them and you don't spend too
much time
analyzing the market identifying
strategic partners understanding the
end user
understanding how to penetrate the
international markets and that's
something that mainly some more
people with international background or
experience in their field can help
create bridging the gap
obviously uh
if you find some strategic investors
that can back you or can open doors to
you that's a very important
way to
to
develop your company
also we've seen that uh bringing some uh
having a global approach is very
important not to be
focused exclusively on the u.s market
many of these many entrepreneurs are
very much because of the english maybe
or starting with the us but the asian
market could be a huge opportunity for
israeli entrepreneurs and also the
european market people may forget that
europe is the first trading partner of
israel and it accesses an accessible
market closer
physically or in terms of geography and
maybe it's less competitive in some of
these the technology sectors so building
partnership also outside of the u.s in
europe indonesia is essential
so where are we headed from here
in the next 28 years
where are we headed in the israeli
ecosystem are we going to
to be to create you know giant
ecosystems and to create giant
multinationals you know within our tiny
tiny country in the middle east
are we going to you know stay on this
trajectory of you know unicorns that are
either selling or ipointing for
for for the amount that they are today
where do you see things going i do think
there is a huge opportunity for
israeli
ecosystem to continue to grow you know
if you look at the number of unicorns
that have grown exponentially we were
one unicorn in 2013
we were 18 unicorn in 2019
we are
66 unicorns on top of the 20 that went
public only this year
so we are having an expectation to reach
in q to 100 unicorns
and
maybe some challenges on the way we've
seen the prices of 2000 and 2008 that
suddenly the market are shutting down
but
if you have a strong technology that are
uh targeting uh global market and they
have the leading uh
technology eventually the sky is limited
so may take more time more resources
you know the the allocation uh
in the venture capital industry is
growing uh we've just
seen the money that was injected by
venture funding to israel has gone from
one billion 10 years ago to 20 billion
dollars this year and i think the number
will continue to grow
and most importantly on top of the 300
yeah 380 israeli venture funds you have
now
international funds
investing directly in israel some of the
bigger names
whether it's blackstone
softbank
tpg all those big players inside have
been decided i've decided to
develop their operation here but i think
that the
uh the
investment
in the israeli ecosystem will only go
will only grow in the coming years we
see that also from the european
investors that
traditionally would invest exclusively
in europe
and now they're really open to uh
to invest in israel and
that's really
a much easier sale than what it was when
we started
taking israeli companies public in
france in germany in switzerland and in
the uk
incredible edward i want to
i thank you thank you a lot for not just
for these 20 minutes but for everything
you've done to israel and to the israeli
ecosystem i'm inspired by your vision
and by
um your zionism and by your
intentionality behind everything that
you do and you've done so thank you for
serving as an inspiration for me and i'm
sure for many many others and and
continue making incredible things for
the country and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you very much thank you
very much
hmm